bonsoir messieurs qui qui est un visio
bonsoir mes chers collègues bonsoir
Monsieur
monsieur Foucault mes chers collègues
avant d'ouvrir l'audition de cette fin
d'après-midi notre première audition
pour nos premiers travaux sur cette
mission d'information sur l'avenir de la
commune du maire en France quelques mots
sur l'organisation de nos travaux alors
comme vous l'avez vu dans le programme
prévisionnel qui vous a été adressé nous
essaierons dans les prochaines semaines
de tenir un rythme d'une audition
plénière tous les 15 jours et
parallèlement nous vous proposons de
participer bien sûr à nos déplacements
généralement organisé le lundi qui nous
permettront de voir au plus près du
terrain et réalité évoquer au cours de
nos échanges le premier déplacement dont
vous avez été déjà averti chers
collègues se fera la semaine du 13 mars
le lundi 13 mars et sera dans les Vosges
par ailleurs avec le rapporteur je
remercie ceux d'entre vous qui depuis
notre dernière réunion nous en fait
passer d'utile suggestion d'audition ou
d'éclairage particulier nous avons
essayé d'en tenir compte dans la
programmation des travaux que nous vous
souhaitons
je salue également la présence de
Françoise Gatel notre collègue
présidente de la délégation au
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation qui travaillent
également sur la question du blues des
maires et à laquelle nous avons donc
proposé de ce joindre à nous pour notre
audition d'aujourd'hui merci Françoise
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous proposer
d'ores et déjà de d'ouvrir notre
première table ronde consacrée dans à la
crise de vocation des maires nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir quatre anciens
maires qui ont accepté de témoigner sur
les difficultés d'exercices de leur
mandat et les raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont décidé de démissionner ou
renoncer à se représenter merci
messieurs qui êtes en visio alors sont
ici présents en visioconférence monsieur
Gilles Cadoret ancien maire de la
commune de Saint-Aignan dans le Morbihan
Monsieur Emmanuel eloret ancien maire
d'Andouillé Neuville à Ille-et-Vilaine
Jean-Luc Vagnon ancien maire de
longsaulve dans l'Aube monsieur Claude
Landos ancien maire de la celle du noise
dans la Creuse et enfin je salue
également en présentiel la présence de
Monsieur martial Foucault professeur de
sciences politiques et directeur du Sevi
pof qui pourra compléter les témoignages
des précédents invités avec l'analyse
particulière du chercheur
alors messieurs comme vous le savez
l'objet de notre mission d'information
et de s'interroger sur l'avenir de la
commune et du maire quel peut-il être
quelle petit être cet avenir qu'elle
menace pèse sur lui qu'elles espoirs
portent-ils en lui et surtout à quelles
conditions pourra-t-il se réaliser or
chacun ici a pu le constater dans son
département et plusieurs centres travaux
scientifiques l'ont confirmé on assiste
à une crise de vocation qui se dessine
depuis plusieurs années et les dernières
élections municipales en fournit une
illustration on a aussi pu parler de
ras-le-bol ou de blues des mers et si le
phénomène n'est pas majoritaire il
manifeste à notre sens les difficultés
de l'exercice du mandat municipal
aujourd'hui or avant de parler de
l'avenir et pour le préparer au mieux il
est important de savoir d'où l'on part
c'est pourquoi votre témoignage nous
sera précieux messieurs puisqu'il rendra
compte des raisons pour lequel vous avez
hésité à vous représenter ou vous avez
décidé de démissionner de votre mandat
alors avant de je vous propose d'engager
dès à présent nos échanges autour de
notre rapporteur et je vais vous donner
dans un premier temps la parole pour
exposer succinctement votre analyse sur
le sujet puis avant de donner la parole
à Mathieu et à nos collègues ici
présents pour qu'ils vous interroge à
leur tour j'inviterai monsieur martial
fourc Foucault à nous livrer son analyse
sur cette crise de vocation son ampleur
ces manifestations ces causes et les
solutions qui pourraient qui pourraient
être apportées je vous précise aussi que
nos échanges sont aujourd'hui retransmis
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
je vous remercie monsieur rapporteur
vous avez ce stade non je ne vais pas à
ce stade rajouter aux propos
de la présidente qui a parfaitement
rappelé qu'elles étaient les objectifs
de cette audition je vais tout de suite
vous donner la parole et puis je crois
que le mieux c'est que nous puissions
avoir un échange le plus interactif
possible
on commence peut-être par Monsieur
Cadoret
bonjour à tous bonjour
donc monsieur Cadoret qu'est-ce que vous
avez à nous dire
mais en tant que maire mais autrement
j'étais je suis élu depuis 2008 tant
conseiller puis en 2011 j'étais passé
premier adjoint donc c'était un peu la
continuité de comment de ma vision de la
commune et puis donc voilà j'ai pas
engagé beaucoup dans les associations
donc c'est c'était rempli un peu plus
proche des personnes peut-être et puis
de mettre en avant tous nos projets
qu'on avait à mettre pour notre petite
commune
c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé
sur la commune de Saint-Aignan
très bien et vous avez des missionné
[Musique]
on avait un projet même si c'était pas
notre projet de à la commune même
c'était mon voisin d'à côté qui avait un
projet pour pour nos deux communes qui
étaient très intéressantes
pour ma part une passerelle qui passe
qui rejoignait nos deux communes par
au-dessus du lac qui comme qui touche
nos deux nos documents nos deux
départements donc c'était un peu une
vision de voir un rapprochement entre
nos deux communes nos deux départements
nos deux intercoms donc c'était très
intéressant c'était très intéressant
pour ça malheureusement
comment une partie de mon conseil
n'était pas du tout chaud à cette
comment ce projet est donc voilà c'est
ça a commencé très rapidement à être
très dur dans le conseil
que la partie de la population
ils étaient très peu au départ et puis
donc forcément amener des courriers
des
j'ai eu droit à un journal ok sur mon
nom donc voilà ça a été très très dur
pour ça on adjoint qui a fait une taper
dessus donc un moment donné
on se dit que non on n'est pas là pour
ça donc c'est pour ça que j'ai fini au
bout d'un an à abandonner quand même mon
mandat voilà c'est un peu ça
dans les grandes lignes
très bien on passe peut-être à Monsieur
et l'aurait qui va nous qui va nous dire
aussi
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à travailler
en Ille-et-Vilaine
je n'aurais jamais dû avoir recours
à la démission c'est une j'allais dire
c'est de mon parcours
le concept d'admission est arrivé parce
que je en 2000 lors des élections
j'avais envisagé de ne pas me
représenter et
devant l'absence de candidats et pour ne
pas laisser les choses en l'étage et
repris un goût de mandat avec le ferme
de propos de ne pas aller trop loin à
partir du moment où je retrouvais
quelqu'un pour prendre le relais ce qui
fut fait assez rapidement et quand
dans le conseil quelqu'un s'est révélé
apte à prendre le relais j'ai donc posé
ma démission pour laisser le champ libre
mon successeur pour pouvoir continuer la
mission tout simplement
vous avez trouvé vous avez eu du mal à
trouver un successeur
dans le mandat que j'ai assuré
précédemment oui j'avais eu du mal à
trouver un successeur et j'ai donc
accepter de
recomposer une liste pour pouvoir
reprendre
mais j'avais prévenu tous mes collègues
dès le départ que à partir du moment où
quelqu'un se serait
en mesure de prendre le relais je me
retirer parce que j'étais atteint par la
limite d'âge comme on dit à 82 ans que
je souhaitais me retirer tout simplement
très bien monsieur Vagnon
enfin j'étais donc en fait
en 89
j'ai fait un mois d'aide conseiller
j'étais comme dans un adjoint et puis un
modèle de demain
donc les éléments qui m'ont poussé
arrêter c'est en fait une conseillère
qui m'a
agressé
sur un sujet sans fondement donc je me
suis dit que
vous avez certainement mal tourné donc
il va lui dire donc en fait je voulais
pas non plus abandonner parce qu'en fait
les dossiers en cours et tout j'avais
dit je me représenterai pas comme mère
mais je le voyais pas la commune que je
ne représenterai comme conseiller ce que
j'ai fait
mais bon je peux vous dire que bon allez
ça c'est très mal passé
plusieurs années de conseils parce que
je me suis fait agresser par
les nouveaux élus qui préparé un petit
quelque chose bon ils ont
la galette la conseillère avait agressé
[Musique]
pendant quelques années pour acheter une
propriété contribue à la mairie et la
première chose qu'ils ont fait et bien
ils ont vendu
la profonde
donc je trouve que c'est des éléments
vraiment dramatiques je comprends pas on
peut on veut pas non plus faire une
polémique là-dessus des fois moi je
trouve
que c'est compliqué donc voilà l'état
d'esprit de la commune dont j'ai du mal
je comprends pas
comment des gens peuvent arriver à faire
des choses pareilles
voilà ce que j'avais à dire
merci et pour finir monsieur monsieur
Landos
oui bonjour tout le monde merci de
pour cette enquête qui peut peut-être en
effet faire avancer les choses donc moi
je suis enfin j'étais plutôt maire d'une
petite commune de creuse donc en pleine
ruralité donc avec toutes les
difficultés que l'on peut imaginer comme
une de 560 habitants
j'ai commencé donc des va être élus en
2008 mais j'étais élu entre guillemets
de l'opposition en tout cas le maire de
l'époque ma catalogué comme ça parce que
je faisais pas partie de son équipe il
m'avait pas demandé sinon j'aurais
volontiers accepté et puis bon en fait
le mandat s'est passé tout à fait bien
je moi j'ai appris donc le travail d'un
élu à ce moment-là et donc avec une
bonne collaboration avec toute l'équipe
bon est arrivé 2014
poser la question aux collègues est-ce
que FAQ est-ce qui est prêt pour se
représenter de collecte de l'ancienne
équipe bon et personne n'était prêt à se
représenter donc j'ai fait une réunion
publique organise une réunion publique
où il y a eu pas mal de personnes qui
qui sont venus intéressés par la commune
des gens que je connaissais d'autres que
je ne connaissais pas et puis à la fin
de la réunion la l'équipe était faite
mais un petit peu hétéroclite parce que
on se connaissait pas forcément on
n'avait pas de enfin on avait un vague
programme mais mais c'était c'était
quand même quelque chose à élaborer donc
nous nous sommes présentés bon il y a eu
une équipe qui s'est présentée contre
nous mais nous avons tous été élu dans
notre équipe et aucun de l'autre de
l'autre équipe donc nous avons travaillé
pendant les six ans et je dirais en
bonne entente avec une équipe d'adjoints
qui travailler qui était complémentaire
une bonne ambiance et donc tout s'est
bien passé
est arrivé donc le covid et puis les
élections sont mis un petit peu de souci
par rapport à la suite et donc les hélas
dans l'équipe qui était avec moi bon
beaucoup ne voulaient pas se représenter
parce que c'est un des problèmes que je
pense qui peut être évoqué dans notre
réunion c'est que des gens jeunes actifs
ne sont pas trop disponibles et donc
certains se sont épuisés et après ça
peut être au contraire la limite d'âge
où on se dit
on va arrêter parce que
bon on est on est trop vieux bon je sais
pas si on est réellement trop vieux on a
toujours des choses à apporter mais
peut-être un engagement différent
donc j'ai mené le l'Autre
Campagne donc il y a eu qu'une seule
équipe qui s'est présentée donc bien sûr
tout le monde a été élu et donc nous
avons commencé à travailler mais je
dirais que l'ambiance n'était plus la
même que la première fois donc avec
donc certaines difficultés bon il y a eu
le covid je crois qu'on lui a tous vécu
et ça ça amène quand même un certain
nombre de difficultés et puis des
personnes qui étaient plus jeunes qui ne
connaissait pas trop le travail des élus
et qui
a amené des difficultés des difficultés
avec le secrétariat de mairie aussi la
secrétaire qui a fait un burn out et qui
s'est mis en arrêt alors que bon c'est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup une de
la démission aussi par rapport à un
projet de de la deuxième adj ointe
avec qui je m'entendais parfaitement
et donc je me suis posé la question à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce que je fais ce que
je continue ou est-ce que je m'arrête et
donc bon je me suis dit j'ai été lui il
faut que je continue même si j'avais
prévu de m'arrêter à mi-mandat parce que
je suis toujours actif je suis médecin
médecin de campagne et donc je fais donc
un mi-temps de médecins c'est-à-dire 12
heures par jour et puis le reste après
donc le boulot de
maire et puis et puis aussi engagement
associatif et autres donc vous voyez
c'est un peu la difficulté ça laisse peu
de temps pour pour soi ou pour récupérer
bon donc l'ambiance c'était pas la même
je dirais même si je m'entendais bien
avec certaines personnes
bon c'était un petit peu conflictuel et
puis
bon donc j'ai choisi de démissionner
parce que j'avais pas envie de j'avais
envie de d'avancer mais pas de me
bagarrer au quotidien avec les personnes
qui n'étaient pas d'accord et j'ai
choisi donc de continuer mon travail de
médecins généralistes où je suis actif
donc là j'ai bien baisser mes patients
mais je vais retourner les voir après la
réunion et puis
donc qui s'accompagne d'un boulot avec
l'ARS avec bon aussi les maires je
participe à certains nombre de
commissions et j'essaie de faire avancer
la démographie médicale qui est qui est
bien en berne dans la Creuse mais aussi
un peu partout donc je ne m'ennuie pas
je regrette un peu parce que le boulot
de mer est un boulot passionnant mais
donc on pourra on pourra en parler un
peu plus tout à l'heure certainement
voilà donc j'ai choisi de garder mon
travail
parce que je
bon c'est un travail qui est passionnant
et aussi comme on a vu tout à l'heure
par rapport donc à des conflits internes
et qui parfois sont
usant c'est difficile et donc il faut
quand même se préserver un petit peu
voilà donc merci
merci à chacun d'entre vous peut-être
une question avant de passer la parole à
Martial Foucault et puis Françoise Gatel
et nos collègues en une ou deux phrases
pour être le plus synthétique possible
on a bien compris qu'il y a eu un fait
générateur qui a j'allais dire
déboucher sur votre votre démission
votre souhait de quitter votre mandat
mais si vous deviez je veux dire
qualifier ou définir quels ont été les
les écueils que vous avez les plus
importants que vous avez rencontré dans
dans l'exercice de votre mandat local et
l'autre l'autre question c'est comment
voyez-vous l'évolution et surtout selon
vous qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour que
justement ces écueils que vous avez pu
rencontrer puisse être puissent être
levé pour redonner en quelque sorte
c'est un peu le l'objet de notre mission
du du souffle
à cette à cette France communale à la
commune et puis surtout faciliter
l'exercice du mandat du mandat de maire
ou du mandat local
on peut refaire le même tour monsieur
Cadoré
vous pouvez répéter votre question parce
que elle a été un peu longue là j'ai pas
pardon je vais être très court qu'est-ce
qui est au-delà du fait générateur on a
bien compris le projet qui avait avorté
vous concernant quels ont été les grands
écueils et les difficultés majeures que
vous avez rencontrées durant votre
l'exercice de votre mandat et selon vous
quels sont les priorités de ce qu'il
faut revoir pour faciliter l'exercice du
mandat de maire à l'avenir
en phase avec moi c'était plus ça
devenait très compliqué quoi quand on a
une partie de la population qui vient au
conseil avec des slogans des pancartes
contre cette passerelle
comme voilà c'est ça devient trop dur
comme on pense fait agresser
physiquement dans
quand on traverse la commune c'est plus
possible il y a un moment donné
je pense que
le fait que c'était des amis au départ
mon premier adjoint c'était un de mes
meilleures amies c'est peut-être ça
aussi l'erreur qu'on fait peut-être
beaucoup de personnes c'est que on se
rapproche avec des personnes qu'on
connaît bien et comme qui ont des
compétences bien sûr mais voilà et
peut-être que on s'attend pas à ce que
cette personne là puisse nous trahir on
va dire c'est comme ça que je l'ai
ressenti
[Musique]
merci Monsieur et Lauret
oui je voudrais dire le travail de mère
est un travail passionnant c'est
enthousiasmant mais devient de plus en
plus lourd pour une petite commune de la
commune rurales en particulier et j'ai
eu l'occasion française Gatel le dire
devant l'ouvrir à elle parce que le
[Musique]
ce qui déterminé encore plus mon souhait
de quitter si vous voulez c'est toutes
les problématiques liées à l'urbanisme
qui devient de plus en plus difficile
à cerner
autre chose c'est toute la relation avec
les communautés de communes dans les
contours ne sont pas à mon avis très
bien défini et où chacun essaie de de
tirer les choses à soi et je pense que
là il y a peut-être une réflexion
conduire au niveau de la relation de
lien entre communautés de communes et
communes
on a le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui la
communauté de le maire ne j'allais dire
ne sert plus à rien le mot est fort mais
la communauté de communes il y a de plus
en plus de compétences qui sont allés à
la communauté de communes et on a
l'impression de devenir un peu des
marionnettes au niveau de
au niveau des communes tant que ça je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose à revoir à
ce niveau là et ça se traduit beaucoup
sur le plan de l'urbanisme et autres
compétences particulières je pense qui
entraîne des difficultés et tout ce qui
concerne l'assainissement et vous savez
que dans en 2026 l'assainissement
passera obligatoirement en compétences
communautés et c'est une des choses si
vous voulez qui une des compétences qui
au niveau du maire recouvrait lui
permettre d'avoir une certaine utilité
le sentiment d'une certaine utilité et
au niveau de sa commune je pense que ces
choses-là devrait être repensées et je
sais que le Sénat s'en est emparé de la
question mais
voilà j'en suis c'est une des raisons
que j'évoquerai si vous voulez qui
motivait aussi mon départ
merci Monsieur Vagnon à qui je dois
signaler qu'il faut qu'il remette sa
caméra me dit-on
est-ce que vous nous entendez monsieur
Wagnon
nous vous voyons
voilà c'est bon parfait
[Musique]
es
il y a le meilleur fait un peu tout on a
beaucoup de on est beaucoup sollicité et
si on veut s'investir et bien il y a
beaucoup de temps y passer
d'autant plus maintenant qu'on se
retrouve obligatoirement dans les
communautés de communes donc si on veut
un peu rester au courant de ce qui se
passe étant donné qu'il y a de plus en
plus de compétences qui sont transférées
ça demande beaucoup de réunions mais
c'est beaucoup de réunions souvent
écouter et on n'a pas on n'a pas
l'impression de d'avoir un grand rôle
totalement je pense de notre communauté
de communes ou on a une petite
communauté de communes mais on a une
communauté de copine à cheval sur deux
cantons et donc si vous voulez il y a
en gros une dizaine de communes qui sont
sur sur un canton une fois ce qui sont
sur un autre et le président de la
communauté commune est devenu
comment conseiller départemental
du canton qui représente le plus de
communes les trois petites communes
qui sont de l'autre cantons je pense que
ils ont plus grand chose à dire et on a
vu qu'à écouter le regarder
je trouve pas normal que forcément elle
est nulle
on s'est débarquement
il va plus verser
des gens très compétents des gens
agréables
et tout au sein des ministration autant
j'étais j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de
soucis avec notamment les AVFs qui sont
des gens qui ont tout pouvoir donc on a
des on a une église qui est
inscrit pour réussir des bâtiments en
France et donc à ce niveau-là c'est pas
l'architecte des bâtiments
de France qui supervise les travaux mais
on a le droit de prendre un architecte
privé donc c'est toujours une guerre pas
possible parce que évidemment lui
bâtiment de France veut imposer
son avis et souvent et chez nous entre
autres je pense que il y a des travaux
qui ont été faits pour moi c'est
dramatique sous prétexte qui va avoir la
dernier mot il y a on fait faire les
choses qui ne dure pas dans le temps
pour moi c'est un peu d'argent je trouve
ça
donc c'est ce que j'avais à dire
concernant les relations donc les
différents acteurs qu'on peut avoir
jusqu'à la commune
les deux principes
un peu comme merci beaucoup et Monsieur
landau pour pour finir ce tour
oui
bon l'homme veut dire les difficultés
qu'il y a eu quand j'étais mère la
première fois donc lors de mon mandat il
y a eu bien sûr des difficultés bon
c'est occuper de l'assainissement
assainissement
donc général de la Commune donc ça soit
le bourg et que ça que ça soit les les
hameaux donc il y a eu des conflits
aussi avec les certaines personnes des
hameaux parce qu'ils étaient mécontents
et je veux dire ça on a géré on une
équipe qui était soudée et ça je dirais
c'est la chose fondamentale quand on est
dans une équipe qui est soudée bon je
dois dire aussi que j'ai eu des grosses
soucis de santé lors de mon premier
mandat mais ces soucis de santé ont été
gérés parce que nous avons travaillé en
équipe quand j'étais pas disponible
j'étais en contact avec les collègues et
puis donc tout s'est passé bien tout à
fait bien dans le deuxième mandat
l'équipe était donc divisée bon il y
avait enfin je dirais 50% de dans un
sens 50% dans un autre donc c'était
parfois animé difficile bon il fallait
quand même essayer d'avancer et puis bon
il y a eu la défection de ma deuxième
adjointe ce qui fait que j'étais devenu
minoritaire donc compliqué et puis comme
je vous avais dit avec mon travail à
côté c'est difficile tranquille et je
vais pas envie de me prendre la tête et
de passer
du temps dans les conflits donc j'ai
préféré m'arrêter
sinon
avec les administrations bon ça s'est
passé relativement bien chez nous nous
avons pas eu trop de problèmes
sauf bon c'est un problème que mes
collègues ont dû aussi rencontrer qu'on
rencontre à nouveau en ce moment c'est
par rapport aux écoles les fermetures de
classe nous nous sommes battus pour
garder des classes nous nous sommes
battus aussi pour garder des services et
c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est quelque chose qui est
usant et puis je dirais que par rapport
à ça même si nous avions gardé nous
avons nous avions deux classes dans
l'école au sein des regroupement
pédagogiques et nous avions lutté nous
avons gardé nos classes et puis là le
rouleau compresseur a continué à avancer
nous avons perdu nous avons perdu une
classe
après c'est aussi
comme je vous ai dit le problème de la
démographie médicale dans la commune
voisine donc il y avait 7 médecins quand
je suis arrivé donc 86
là actuellement il n'y a plus que deux
médecins mi-temps bon et je vous passe
les autres communes avec aussi les
défections ou les départs en retraite de
collègue ce qui fait que ça donne un
emploi du temps qui est extrêmement
chargé alors par rapport à ça bien sûr
on essaye de lutter lutter avec les
collègues au sein de des associations de
maire par exemple
ou donc avec les collègues syndiqués ou
autre pensée par rapport aux problèmes
médicaux mais mais on voit que malgré
tout
on pêche souvent un petit peu dans le
désert les choses ne bougent pas
n'avance pas par contre c'est pas faute
de de réunion j'ai participé enfin de
nombreuses réunions au sein de la comcom
de nombreuses réunions avec l'ARS la
préfecture avec les collègues mère j'ai
participé au CNR qui a eu lieu là il y a
un peu de temps bon ce qui est ça c'est
un des problèmes que je soulève quand
nous allions dans des réunions donc soit
elles sont choisies et calculer pour
nous faire perdre notre temps et nous
épuiser on peut se poser la question
soit
les conclusions sont déjà faites au
départ et bon par exemple j'ai été aux
réunion du CNR j'ai exprimé un certain
nombre d'idées notamment par rapport à
la démographie médicale aucune de mes
idées n'a été reprise et j'ai vu les
conclusions qui ont été faites à
l'échelle de la nouvelle Aquitaine parce
que c'est conclusion nouvelle-aquitaine
et je suis du brassage de de généralité
donc est-ce que on fait des réunions
pour avancer ou alors est-ce que et donc
on est pris en compte et je crois que
quand on est dans la base parce que
l'homme maintenant je suis dans la base
au point de vue médical j'ai un certain
nombre d'informations et on a la chance
nous
rencontrer les gens au quotidien
on connaît un certain nombre de
problèmes on va dans les maisons la plus
petite chaumière on a plus de choses
donc on rencontre les gens avec leurs
difficultés qui vont croissant et
c'est réunions qui sont des des grands
messes alors je suis peut-être un peu
critique il peut parfois sortir des
choses mais bon il faut essayer quelque
part d'être dans le concret et si on
n'est pas dans le concret je veux dire
un moment ça finit par les épuiser et
puis on jette l'éponge
merci
éventuellement mais voilà merci beaucoup
je vous propose maintenant de passer la
parole à Martial Foucault on a une
vision territoriale micro peut-être
passer une vision plus macro sur
sa vision sur sur ce sujet et puis après
peut-être laisser la parole à Françoise
Gatel à moins que tu veuilles parler
tout de suite Françoise vas-y je passe
la parole et puis comme ça
merci bonjour à tous permettez-moi
d'avoir à nouveau un salut particulier
pour Emmanuel et l'aurait mère
d'Andouillé Neuville qui a eu comme
beaucoup de mains le souci de la relève
si je puis dire Ikea accepté
d'enclencher un nouveau mandat en
attendant qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui
veuille bien prendre justement sur alors
moi ce que l'impression que j'ai c'est
que ça n'est pas forcément l'ampleur de
la tâche de l'engagement et du temps que
sa complexité vous l'avez dit et surtout
ce qui apparaît de plus en plus c'est la
fragilité des équipes et on sent que sur
ce mandat 2020 avec cette période
bizarre de mise en place se déconseille
municipaux le covid n'a pas facilité la
cohésion des équipes est-ce qu'on
constate qu'il y a plus de démission que
d'habitude alors moi j'aurais une ou
deux questions ou suggestions c'est pas
des suggestions mais des questions
est-ce que vous pensez que il serait
utile que notamment les associations de
maire enfin les associations
départementales proposent aux maires que
nous devenons une formation un peu à la
conduite des équipes parce que on voit
que chacun de nous devient mère avec son
expérience professionnelle on apprend et
qu'il faut pouvoir
une cohésion d'équipe quand l'équipe est
faite de gens très différents qui n'ont
ensemble que le fait justement d'être
différent pour représenter la totalité
de la commune donc première question un
peu sur cette accompagnement d'une
association à la gestion d'équipe
deuxième chose alors c'était le cas
d'andouiller Neuville cher Emmanuel mais
peut-être d'autres on a vu l'effet de la
loi notre dans beaucoup de territoires
et de la fusion du mariage forcé
d'intercommunalité qui a parfois fait
glisser d'une intercommunalité où on se
connaissait voilà une intercommunalité
plus grande ou on a encore du mal à se
trouver un projet partagé et une autre
question qui est celle est-ce que vous
avez l'écoute du sous-préfet
parce que souvent les petits communes
nous disent moi quand j'ai une question
le sous-préfet il est tout le temps là
et j'arrive à régler les problèmes et
d'autres nous disent le sous-préfet
n'est pas très présent à mes côtés donc
j'aimerais bien voir votre avis
là-dessus et puis dernière question on
évoque beaucoup la question du scrutin
list on distinguant la constitution des
équipes municipales dans les équipes de
moins de 1000 où là on a des élections
qui sont faites par conseiller municipal
si je puis dire on se retrouve avec un
conseil municipal qui est constitué
après les élections sans forcément avoir
eu la possibilité de faire une équipe et
donc d'avoir un projet partagé alors
est-ce que vous pensez que l'évolution
du scrutin de list en tout cas son
abaissement
de seuil peut être en quelque sorte un
remède et en tout cas éviter
l'éclatement d'équipe parce que on a
pris le temps avant les élections de
travailler ensemble et d'avoir un projet
qui doit nous réunir et qui permet de
coaguler l'équipe merci à chacun de vous
pour votre engagement pour cette
audition très intéressante
qui veut répondre
avant qu'on passe à Monsieur martial
Foucault
[Musique]
es
j'étais adjoint
l'ancien maire ne représentait pas donc
j'ai on avait fini par ne puisse
entendre la dernière année donc c'était
un peu compliqué c'était même très
actuelle mais du coup manger j'ai prises
à place en
vouloir l'apprendre c'était si c'était
représenté je restais comment en dehors
du conseil pour final mais bon du coup
j'ai réussi à garder une partie de
l'ancien conseil avec moi et on a on a
creusé pour trouver d'autres personnes
mais pour moi c'était vraiment chercher
une comment un nombre de personnes pas
forcément politiquement quoi c'était on
cherchait on est 630 habitants on va pas
prendre des gens que de droite ou que de
gauche il faut que tout le monde soit
dans un conseil enfin moi c'est pas ce
que je vois les choses je pense que vous
êtes tous pareils
et autrement non
cette vision là de prendre
le maire c'est un tel et ainsi de suite
je pense pas que ça soit pour nos
petites communes ce sont intéressantes
bon par rapport à la question sur la
formation
nous avons eu en Creuse en tout cas des
formations
par la MF qui nous a quand même aidé
dans un certain nombre de
un certain nombre de compétences après
une des difficultés bien sûr que nous
avons mais qui peuvent se résoudre aussi
avec la comcom c'est le problème des
compétences bon dans notre petite
commune nous avons
donc peu de d'employés et qui doivent
être vraiment polyvalents enfin le
boulot de secrétaire de mairie est
extrêmement complexe parce que le
secrétaire la secrétaire doit être
compétent partout bon c'est quelque
chose qui peut être dépassé si un
certain nombre de tâches sont confiées
au com comme bon vous parliez de la loi
notre tout à l'heure bon nous avons été
dans mon premier mandat dans une comcom
et puis on a fait les entre les honneurs
des médias parce que
le maire de du canton à côté enfin de de
mon canton a dit bah non on veut plus
être là-bas et donc on était la première
comme comme qui a éclaté parce que
personnellement moi j'ai beaucoup
regretté parce que on avait commencé à
avoir et c'est bien voir une comme
suffisamment grande on peut trouver des
atomes crochus avec des collègues et
avancer dans des dossiers par contre
c'est vrai que les dossiers sont quand
même extrêmement lourds et c'est la
question à se poser faut-il être
retraités pour être élu ou en tout cas
quand on est maire ou adjoint ou alors
est-ce que c'est aussi possible pour les
gens actifs c'est et là j'ai pas de
solution
oui je veux bien prendre le relais
effectivement la notion de formation que
pose Françoise Gatel me paraît essentiel
parce que le maire surtout dans nos
petites communes il y a nous avons un
véritable rôle de
parce que une aiguille une équipe comme
vous le dites
[Musique]
donnez-moi l'expression de briques et de
broc il faut arriver à faire en sorte
que tout ce monde a s'entende il faut
arriver à définir une ligne commune il
faut arriver à
définir un projet et les choses ne se
font pas comme ça ce n'est pas en
claquant d'Edward parce que le maire
peut avoir un certain nombre
mais une idée on sait bien elle est
bonne que c'est les partager et faire
arriver à faire partager les choses ce
n'est pas chose facile donc
ça c'est le premier aspect pour répondre
à la question de Françoise la deuxième
question concernant la relation avec le
préfet ou le sous-préfet bien on sait
très bien que le maire
on sait très bien toutes les
responsabilités qui posent sur qui lui
pèse sur les épaules à la moindre erreur
on sait que le sous-préféren ne tombait
dessus sauf par ailleurs on n'a pas la
possibilité d'échanger avec le
sous-préfet donc moi je pense l'un de ce
côté là il y a des choses à améliorer
effectivement et enfin concernant la
relation avec la communauté de communes
je pense que
beaucoup de choses sont à revoir à ce
niveau-là
merci et je crois que Monsieur Vagnon je
sais pas si nous entend s'il peut
également porter quelques éléments
[Musique]
bien informé en ce qui concerne toutes
les formations donc j'ai pu
effectivement sur des belles formations
département
je pense que par contre
l'évolution au niveau de l'aide des mers
une réexister un espèce de registre
numérique dans lequel le maire il
pourrait prendre son portable quand il
est dans sa commune et qu'on lui pose
une question ou qu'il a un
souci pour voir un
réponse
doit faire ou ce qu'il peut faire par le
biais de d'un système informatique
et ça serait intéressant
au niveau de la vocation des des élus et
les candidats moi je dirais que ça
devient de plus en plus difficile dans
le petites communes d'avoir des
candidats c'est dommage parce que
dans l'évocation on perd certaines
personnes parce que ils veulent pas
s'engager et jeunes qui ont entre on va
dire entre 30 et 50 ans
dans leur vie active et ils se voient
pas entrer à prendre des responsabilités
au sein de la commune c'est dommage
parce que c'est des gens comme je sais
pas j'y reviendront après mais c'est des
gens qui sont intéressants et qui
malheureusement viennent pas je sais pas
comment on peut les attirer
bon voilà et en ce qui concerne la
troisième
relation avec le préfet nous les
sous-préfecture
personnellement j'ai jamais eu de
problème et j'ai à chaque fois que j'ai
eu
voir des questions des soucis j'ai
interrogé directement la préfecture j'ai
jamais j'ai du temps
voilà ce que j'avais dit
merci peut-être maintenant passer la
parole à Martial Foucault
lui demandant autant que faire ce peu de
reprendre un petit peu tous les toutes
les questions que nous avons posé
au maire et surtout de connaître un peu
son son avis son regard et sa vision sur
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets notamment
bien sûr puisque ça a été un effet
générateur de cette de cette mission
comment il peut qualifier
dire
à la fois ce désamour ou en tout cas se
désengagement à progressif des des élus
et cette crise exprimée par l'ensemble
des collègues anciens maires qui se sont
exprimés des des vocations au niveau
communal
bonsoir merci merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le rapporteur cher
Françoise et Gatel
[Musique]
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très honoré de
participer si j'ai bien compris à la
première audition de cette mission
d'information
j'espère avoir certainement pas les
réponses à toutes les questions qui
m'ont été posées je crois que certaines
d'entre elles doivent venir
impérativement des mères en exercice ou
des mers qui ne sont plus en exercice
comme les quatre mers qui ont d'ores et
déjà témoignés
moi j'ai retenu 8 points alors je sais
pas si le temps elle est en 10 minutes
si vous m'accordez 10 minutes pour
aborder de façon synthétique huit points
qui méritent à mon avis à la fois
d'objectiver un certain nombre de
phénomènes qu'on a coutume parfois de de
lire dans une dans une presse plus
déchaînée que raisonnable sur ces sujets
mais aussi dans le cadre de cette
mission d'information peut-être des
pistes qui pourraient être
explorées
pour pour mieux cerner ce dont on se
dont on parle la première le premier
point c'est la question de la vocation
parce que il est revenu dans
plusieurs témoignages en disant il y a
un risque que au cours des prochaines
décennies il y a une forme de
découragement pour susciter des
candidatures
alors je dirais que sur la question des
vocations
moi dans le travail que j'ai pu mener
notamment dans le cadre d'enquête auprès
des maires mais aussi auprès de larges
échantillons des Français sur leur
propre représentation de la vie dans une
municipalité dans une commune la
question d'évocations elle est elle est
curieuse parce que vous savez vos
questions il y a une dimension très
biblique dans le terme de de vocation il
y aura un appel divin pour être candidat
aux élections municipales et qui
finalement se l'expérience spirituelle
justifierait à elle seule
l'engagement
je crois que c'est un petit peu plus
complexe et on ne peut pas tout ramener
au divin
avec un paradoxe on est le seul pays au
monde capable de réunir presque un
million de personnes lors des élections
municipales si on fait la somme de
toutes les la nature de toutes les
listes un million de personnes sur un
corps électoral
de 46 millions de personnes c'est cette
exceptionnel donc il faut mettre aussi
cela en perspective alors bien sûr il y
a une démographie des communes qui
mécaniquement
nous permet d'avoir ce chiffre
exceptionnel mais finalement on pourrait
n'avoir que la moitié et effectivement
une défection très nombreuse
lorsqu'il s'agit de constituer les
listes pour les élections municipales je
dis paradoxe parce que dans le même
temps
on voit qu'il y a à la fois un
vieillissement
parmi les mers et parmi les équipes
municipales on insiste trop souvent à
tort sur uniquement le maire ou la mer
et il faudrait regarder c'est ce à quoi
je m’emploie la moyenne d'âge des
équipes municipales et c'est un je crois
que c'est un indicateur plus plus
précieux
alors oui un vieillissement il y a une
orientation socio-professionnelle je
crois que tout à l'heure un maire a
indiqué
je crois que c'est Monsieur Lannion qui
est indiqué qu'il y avait
[Musique]
peut-être désormais une vocation pleine
et entière pour des mères retraités
alors oui en l'espace de 20 ans on est
passé de
30% des maires qui étaient retraités à
40% en 2020 donc oui
cela appelle un certain nombre de de
commentaires
et j'y reviendrai sur les sources de
d'insatisfaction ou de démission pour
finir sur ce premier point de de
vocation il y a aussi peut-être parfois
une ambiguïté entre le terme qu'on
associe
à l'exigence du mandat de maire qui est
ambiguïté entre la fonction et le métier
et je salue Eric qui est rouge qui a
aussi travaillé sur ce sujet
c'est une vieille histoire cette
distinction entre métier et fonction et
je crois tout à l'heure j'ai relevé de
maire on parlait du travail de mère et
du boulot de mer en indiquant que
c'était passionnant mais mais au fond ça
veut bien dire que derrière il y a une
activité qui est chronophage qui est
exigeante et qui parfois suscite
beaucoup de
désemparement par rapport à l'attente
des administrés et moi je le vois dans
nos enquêtes c'est très intéressant de
voir que dans les communes de moins de
3500 habitants les maires parlent de
leur mandat comme
d'un métier et dans les communes de
allez surtout plus de 10000 habitants on
parle de fonctions alors ce sont les
effets d'enquête parce qu'on voit bien
que si on répond métier quand on est
maire d'une commune de plus de 50 000
habitants on va tout de suite être
accusés d'avoir
contribué à la professionnalisation de
la fonction donc il y a les effets
d'enquête j'entends mais je trouve que
elle résume assez bien dans les communes
de moins de 3500 habitants si un maire
naturellement parle de métiers plutôt
que de fonction et bien il renvoie
parfois à une
à une forme de solitude par rapport à
une exigence une maîtrise d'un certain
nombre de pratiques qu'elle soit
juridiques qu'elle soit désormais
environnementale d'une connaissance d'un
appareil de l'État déconcentré plutôt
que décentralisé et cela met en
difficulté et peut même parfois
impressionner au titre des des
candidatures deuxième point parce que il
est il est lié la question des
démissions
moi j'avais j'avais été très très
surpris et peut-être que votre mission
d'information permettra d'en savoir un
petit peu plus en 2023 on n'est pas en
capacité d'avoir des données par le
bureau des élections du ministère de
l'Intérieur sur le nombre et les causes
de démission je trouve que si ce sujet
est un sujet d'importance nationale
alors mais peut-être que vous aurez plus
de succès que je n'en ai eu jusqu'à lors
d'avoir des éléments très précis sur les
démissions pour éviter
un certain nombre d'articles parfois
sont saisissants dans les dans les
chiffres et puis on regarde un petit peu
plus précisément
moi je retiens là j'ai demandé des
données au bureau des élections on
m'indique simplement 910 d'émissions
depuis juin 2020
qui sont des démissions volontaires
c'est à dire qu'on ne tient pas compte
des décès on tient pas compte des des
démissions d'office prononcées par un
juge ni celle liée à l'application de la
loi sur le cumul des mandats ou des
fusions de communes une fois qu'on
écarte cela 910 des missions alors
450 par an un petit peu plus 400 par an
on est maintenant à 30 mois
bon et bien ces données qui ne seraient
que volontaires moi il me semble que la
loi oblige tout maire démissionnaire à
informer le préfet
et la cause pourrait au moins à mon sens
puisque on attend de formulaire CERFA on
pourrait peut-être pour la connaissance
commune
indiquer les causes de démission ce qui
éviterait peut-être un certain nombre de
fantasmes sur des démissions qui sont
parfois liées j'entends les conflits
internes dans les conseils municipaux et
on a eu un bel
un beau témoignage il y a quelques
minutes
je rappelle que un maire sur deux
exercent la fonction de mer en même
temps qu'une activité professionnelle un
maire sur deux
donc ça c'est une source première
qui conduit un maire à ne pas vouloir se
représenter
alors je ne dirais pas à démissionner ça
je ne le sais pas mais en tout cas à ne
pas vouloir se représenter c'est
important et deuxième cause c'est la
grande difficulté à concilier la
fonction de maire avec une vie
personnelle
et ça n'a payé il y a un lien de cause à
effet avec le vieillissement de l'âge
des mers
quand on voilà quand on émet à 40 ou 50
ans et qu'on a une vie familiale et
souvent une vie professionnelle la
conciliation de toutes ces obligations
mais un maire en grande en grande
difficulté peut mettre un maire en
grande difficulté
je regardais également je crois que si
je me suis pas trompé dans ma prise de
notes mais
vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le 1er maire qui s'est
exprimé je crois que il s'agit de
Monsieur lénorrhée monsieur Cadoret vous
avez indiqué ne pas avoir une forme de
rite de passage par le milieu associatif
je me trompe peut-être j'ai dans ma
prise de notes c'est très intéressant
parce que dans la socialisation
politique qui conduit souvent à
s'engager comme
colistier puis ensuite qu'on s'est
municipal adjoint maire le passage par
[Musique]
sont renouvelés et vous avez 20% de ceux
qui étaient déjà dans le conseil
municipal qui deviennent mère donc vous
avez quand même un renouvellement qui
est assez soutenu à hauteur de 60% pour
un conseil municipal
alors une fois dit cela les sources de
satisfaction et des satisfactions moi je
veux témoignage recoupe très largement
ce que j'ai pu rassembler dans dans des
verbatim de de mer plus de plus de 6500
maires interrogés avec des verbatim
c'était en
2018 et 2019
je vais pas vous faire la longue le long
inventaire des sources de satisfaction
et des satisfaction mais il y a aussi
des satisfactions à la fonction de maire
et parmi elles moi je j'en citerai d'eux
parce qu'elles sont je crois toujours
importante et l'avenir de la commune et
l'avenir de la fonction de maire
aussi reposer sur une une forme de
réhabilitation de ce qui est perçu comme
une grande source de satisfaction 1
c'est la reconnaissance des administrés
mais on va voir ça peut aller dans
l'autre sens mais c'est aussi la
reconnaissance des administrés
deuxième source de satisfaction la
première la première c'est le sens
civique que les mères mettent en avant
en indiquant que leur engagement se fait
finalement au nom d'une citoyenneté que
eux-mêmes souhaitent
à la fois faire vivre et aussi incarner
donc vous voyez quand on parle parfois
de désengagement du côté des mers on a
on a ici une forme quand même je crois
encore singulière et rafraîchissante de
de ce qu'il de ce qu'il pense en termes
de citoyenneté les deux sources
d'insatisfaction peut-être que les
choses ont évolué depuis 2019 la
première c'était l'absence de
reconnaissance de l'État
pas l'absence de reconnaissance des
administrés c'était avant tout l'absence
de reconnaissance de l'État et dans
l'état c'était avant tout parce qu'on le
voyait dans les Verbatim mais c'était
l'état c'était l'exécutif
et la présidence de la République et le
Premier ministre de l'époque peut-être
que les choses ont évolué en tout cas
moi j'ai hâte de lire vos travaux pour
savoir si si vous observez des
évolutions sur ce terrain-là deuxième
source d'insatisfaction
c'est alors un sujet que que vous avez
déjà traité ici au Sénat mais c'est le
c'est l'inflation l'inflation des normes
[Musique]
dans dans
ce paysage
il y a quand même des éléments du côté
non pas des mers mais des citoyens un
très très fort attachement des Français
à leur municipalité et ça on l'observe
depuis
depuis que des enquêtes posent des
questions sur l'attachement à tous les
niveaux local national européen la
commune ces deux tiers des Français qui
sont profondément attachés à leur
communes on est sur un niveau assez
semblable à celui du pays dans son
ensemble d'accord on est en revanche
beaucoup plus attaché à sa commune qu'à
son canton à son département à sa région
et à l'Europe donc on a ce qui explique
aussi pourquoi les Français maintenant
sur les sur les personnes les élus les
représentants les Français mettent
aujourd'hui le maire vraiment très très
haut parmi les représentants préférés
alors il faut se méfier parce que je
enfin souvenons-nous ça pas toujours été
le cas pour les mœurs il y a eu un
moment de bascule
qu'on peut situer environ à la fin des
milieux des années 90 début des années
90 ou effectivement les mers ont gagné à
une fois en notoriété en légitimité et
en reconnaissant parce que la figure
emblématique préférée des français
jusqu'à cette période c'était le député
au gré d'un certain nombre de
scandales faut pas oublier ce que les
scandales politiques ou financiers ont
fait aux années fin des années 80 début
des années 90 et aussi
une forme de désutilité j'emploie le
terme à dessin de désutilité de la
fonction de député face à l'ampleur de
problématiques qui dépassaient largement
le champ d'action du député c'est le
fameux dilemme l'économie contre le
politique quand on traverse près de 30
ans d'une crise économique et sociale
avec une densité importante
la perception des Français sur
l'incapacité du politique à
tordre une trajectoire de l'économie
alors sa contribue à nourrir cette
désutilité du du député dans en tout cas
dans dans son rôle de fabricants de la
loi donc aujourd'hui le maire et l'élu
préféré français
pour moi ça recoupe deux dimensions
qui sont pas propres au cas de la France
un c'est le lien de proximité il y a une
demande très très forte de proximité je
ne sais pas si pour autant
cela se traduit dans l'esprit des
Français par une demande et pourtant on
a posé les questions mais les résultats
sont très
sont très curieux je vais vous les
livrer je ne sais pas si ça se traduit
pour autant par une demande d'une plus
grande décentralisation je dirais que
dans dans notre pays la culture
politique de décentralisation n'est pas
acquise ni pour les mères ni pour les
citoyens
chez les maires la demande de
décentralisation elle se fait dans des
moments de tension avec l'État
et beaucoup de beaucoup de délu
répondent à l'unisson des Français sur
cette question qui que qui me plaît
beaucoup qui est de mettre en opposition
l'égalité républicaine avec
l'action publique alors qu'est-ce que je
qu'est-ce que j'entends par là
[Musique]
il y a une majorité de mer et une
majorité de Français qui préfèrent
l'efficacité à l'égalité républicaine
et ça je crois que c'est important en
termes d'élaboration de politique
publique notamment locale
la perception de l'égalité chez les
Français qui sont pourtant très attachés
à cette égalité
lorsqu'elle n'est pas couplée combinée à
de l'efficacité alors elle n'est pas
réclamée
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire sur
l'avenir de la commune est-ce qu'il y a
une demande d'un plus grand nombre de
compétences pour pour les maires je
crois que tout à l'heure ça a été évoqué
sur une sur l'enjeu de la politique
d'assainissement
pour pour les mères évidemment les mers
ne veulent n'ont pas envie et ne
s'engage pas pour être simplement
officier d'état civil et donc l'exercice
de la responsabilité politique locale
ils y sont très attachés
et comment on exerce une responsabilité
politique lorsque l'on a de moins en
moins de compétences c'est un c'est un
joli enfin je lui dilemme et d'ailleurs
s'il n'y a plus de responsabilité
politique on peut même s'interroger sur
le bien fondé de maintenir des élections
deux derniers points parce que j'ai été
trop long
dans l'enquête qu'on a mené en 2022 il y
a deux phénomènes que sur lesquels je
voudrais peut-être insister et qui
mériterait
un approfondissement en tout cas moi je
vais continuer d'y travailler
il y a du côté des du côté des mers une
la confirmation de profonde tension
démocratique à l'échelle de leur
territoire et tension démocratique qui
sont à la fois liées dans ce qu'on a pu
observer sur la participation aux
dernières élections
je suis un peu embarrassé pour vous pour
vous dire clairement est-ce que les 20
points de baisse de participation lors
des élections de mars 2020 sont
uniquement liées au covid ou liés à
d'autres phénomènes c'est il y a des bas
sur ce sujet je crois qu'il faut pas
mettre tout sur le dos de la crise covid
mais on peut pas non plus l'écarter
d'accord
les élections présidentielles et
législatives de 2022 au niveau communal
oui on voit une baisse de la
participation
baisse de la participation c'est à dire
dans les territoires où on avait déjà et
les communes on avait observé une baisse
de la participation aux municipale de
2020 on voit que ce sont des territoires
pour lequel la tendance s'est confirmée
pas à un niveau aussi bas qu'en 2020
mais par rapport à la moyenne nationale
dans ces territoires il y a une
confirmation d'un je dirais d'un
relâchement sur sur la participation et
alors ce qui est très intéressant du
côté des mers en 2020 les maires nous
disaient interrogés ce que nous avions
interrogé que cette baisse de la
participation c'était plutôt un
phénomène passager
et que pour des élections municipales
les Français sont tellement attachés à
leur mère qu'il retrouveront le chemin
des bureaux de vote ça c'était en 2020
les mêmes maires interrogés en 2022 sur
cette question est-ce que c'est toujours
un phénomène passager pour ne pas dire
de bêtises
83% nous disent maintenant qui sont très
inquiets car c'est un phénomène plus
profond de désintérêt politique pour une
élection nationale ce qui veut dire que
ils ne sont que 3% à ne pas être inquiet
de ce phénomène parce que les Français
restent attachés à leur mère donc on a
eu en deux ans un point de bascule
considérable sur ce phénomène de
de baisse de la participation alors
pourquoi je parle de polarisation et de
tension démocratique je parle de tension
démocratique parce que il y a aussi chez
les maires la confirmation l'observation
de terrain du d'une forme de
durcissement des opinions politiques
observées au quotidien dans leur
territoire
et aujourd'hui ils sont vous voyez 50% à
observer que oui
et notamment à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle il y a des habitants dans
la commune qui ont des opinions
politiques opposées et qui ont de plus
en plus de difficultés à parler entre
eux à discuter entre eux donc organiser
des réunions publiques parfois je ne
sais pas si c'est une bonne idée
je dis ça presque de façon provocante
mais c'est un sujet qui qui est pas qui
n'est pas anodin et les raisons perçues
du durcissement des des opinions
politiques des administrés
la première là encore ce sont ce sont
les réponses des mers elles sont liées
aux fractures territoriales
ce que beaucoup d'autres ont pu dire et
mieux que moi
que une forme de de oui de division
territoriale aujourd'hui
accentue le sentiment de relégation dans
un certain nombre de communes malgré je
pense qu'on peut il faut pas l'écarter
malgré la réinstallation de l'État à
travers un certain nombre de structures
cette réinstallation ne suffit pas parce
que ce qui est visible c'est pas
seulement une maison franc service ce
qui est visible certains nombre de
services publics efficaces
pas existant efficace fonctionnel
qui ne sont pas interrompus et puis une
autre une autre source de durcissement
ce sont les questions d'inégalité
économiques et sociales ça c'est là
aussi il y a une profonde division je
termine sur les violences à l'endroit
des mers
alors là aussi je pense qu'il faut aller
il faut systématiser le
[Musique]
j'allais dire la remontée d'informations
il faut pouvoir objectiver ce qu'il en
retourne alors je sais qu'il y a il y a
beaucoup d'efforts engagés notamment par
la session des maires de France avec la
gendarmerie nationale nous dans les
enquêtes on a on voit une progression
c'est pas non plus c'est pour ça je vais
être prudent on voit pas un une
explosion de violence à l'endroit des
mers il y a il n'y a pas d'explosion par
exemple de violence physique mais il y a
une explosion des violences symboliques
et celle-ci elles sont très très fortes
et tout à l'heure il y a eu un
témoignage un témoignage qui qui va
finalement dans ce sens c'est-à-dire que
souvent le saint attention parce que la
violence symbolique peut aussi déboucher
sur une violence physique
mais dans dans ces éléments moi ce qui
m'a le plus frappé c'est quand on sait
combien il est difficile pour un maire
pour des raisons évidentes aussi
d'exercices de l'autorité de révéler des
violences subies on peut penser que les
données qu'on nous indique 1000 1500 de
violences déclarées par les mers et
peut-être en dessous de la réalité
d'accord
alors mais il faut regarder ça très
attentivement parce que vous avez des
violences c'est lequel le dire qui sont
moins visibles parce que virtuels et qui
sont extrêmement dommageables
ce qui amène d'ailleurs j'ai été frappé
ce qu'on a posé la question beaucoup de
mères à ne plus utiliser de compte même
institutionnel pour leur commune sur les
réseaux sociaux
parce que c'est un c'est un lieu de
défoulement et qui sont parfois très
violents lorsque le maire ou la mer est
individuellement et
nommément attaqué mais aussi son
entourage familial donc je trouve que
cette question des des violences à
l'endroit des mers
elle est elle est à prendre très au
sérieux
il faut pas non plus mélanger la
violence à l'endroit des des élus comme
étant une forme de catharsis ou le
prolongement de violence dans la société
il y a des points de convergence mais
tout n'est pas expliqué parce que une
société deviendrait plus violente que
les mères en serait le premier
réceptacle je crois qu'il faut regarder
attentivement ce qui conduit aussi des
maires moi c'est ce que j'avais
étudié dans dans cet ouvrage mère au
bord de la crise de nerf c'est à dire
parfois
l'impossibilité ou la quadrature du
cercle c'est l'impossibilité pour des
mers d'être finalement tenu responsable
les mères ne veulent pas être tenues
responsables du tout mais de tout et je
crois que c'est cette distinction elle
est importante parce qu'ils sont tenus
responsables de tous mais ils ne peuvent
pas être responsables du tout et donc
dans le tout pardonnez-moi pour cette
cette expression mais on voit bien que
la relation et moi je trouve que il y
aurait matière à vérifier si
effectivement la crise covid a renoué le
dialogue entre les mères et les
sous-préfectures moi j'avais le
sentiment que les sous-préfectures
jusqu'à la crise covid était plutôt
devenu de grand navires fantômes pour
lesquels il était compliqué pour des
mers d'obtenir le soutien
l'accompagnement la réponse la
réactivité des services des
sous-préfectures peut-être que les
choses ont changé on a également
beaucoup insisté sur le
le couple réhabilité maire préfet en
période covid moi j'ai plusieurs
témoignages qui indiquent le contraire
donc là aussi
il faudrait regarder attentivement dans
quel contexte ce couple a bien
fonctionné est-ce qu'il a bien
fonctionné par ce que le maire était
totalement aligné en quelque sorte
sur les directives de l'État transmise
au préfet et est-ce que on a des cas et
je pourrais citer un certain nombre de
communes dans lesquelles bon et bien des
mers n'ont pas toujours été
finalement admiré par les préfets
lorsqu'ils ont pris des initiatives que
certains préfets ont jugé malheureuse
mais qui était selon les mers la réponse
adaptée à des circonstances
exceptionnelles voilà j'ai été trop long
pardonnez-moi
c'était passionnant en tout cas merci
pour cette analyse et je pense qu'on si
on a besoin de compléments on fera appel
à vous au fur et à mesure de l'avancée
de la mission Christian Redon Sarrasi
avait une question à poser très chère
collègue si vous merci merci Monsieur
pour vos témoignages merci
Monsieur Foucault vous avez en partie
répondu mais j'aimerais quand même avoir
la vie des de nos interlocuteurs en
visio concernant les relations avec les
administrés parce qu'on a parlé beaucoup
de difficultés
au sein même du conseil municipal avec
les interlocuteurs institutionnels peut
de des relations avec avec les
administrés donc c'était juste pour
avoir un éclairage dans vos situations
particulières sur ce champ là de vos
relations
on prend les questions au fur et à
mesure et puis vous répondrez
globalement à la fin
oui merci pour les différentes
interventions à la fois effectivement
avec une entrée très locale sur des cas
particuliers et puis peut-être pour une
vision un peu plus généraliste
moi j'avais une remarque
tout d'abord est-ce que nous n'avons pas
un biais collectif alors certainement en
tant qu'individu nous en avons tous
a toujours regardé finalement les cas
qui ne vont pas alors c'est un bien qui
peut être nécessaire et indispensable on
parle là de la démocratie et donc j'ai
envie de dire si en démocratie il y a ne
serait-ce qu'un cas qui ne fonctionne
pas il nous appartient pour la préserver
de toujours en avoir le souci cependant
et la table ronde de ce soir on est un
exemple on s'intéresse beaucoup par
exemple aux élus qui ont arrêté leur
mandat on ne s'intéresse assez peu à une
autre catégorie d'élus qui existe pour
autant et qui à mon avis est dans des
proportions non négligeables non plus
même si elle n'est pas majoritaire
d'élus qui ne cessent pas de s'arrêter
qui s'arrête parfois parce que les
électeurs ont décidé autrement mais qui
pour certains
voilà continue mandat après mandat et
donc doivent aussi trouver en tout cas
des intérêts donc la question n'est pas
d'opposer une vision négative ou
positive mais mais voilà est-ce que
est-ce que finalement tous les cas
évoqués et parfois avec justesse ne nous
amène pas un une forme d'erreur de
tropisme qui viserait finalement à avoir
une vision assez sombre de notre
démocratie locale plutôt qu'une version
positive et ni dans un cahier dans un
autre il s'agit d'être dans une forme de
machiavélisme bien évidemment mais en
tout cas de réfléchir tout de même aussi
à une démocratie locale qui a tenu et
malgré compris cette crise sanitaire
malgré la tension les crises à la crise
énergétique et d'inflation à laquelle
nous sommes soumis dans tous nos
territoires là pour le coup on sent
quand même une démocratie locale qui qui
persiste après j'avais deux questions
peut-être une question très impertinente
messieurs et je m'en excuse
est-ce que la question du vieillissement
et pour un certain nombre vous nous avez
donné vos âges donc je ne fais offense à
personne ici la question du
vieillissement effectivement de
du stock on va le dire des élus locaux
n'incitent pas plus qu'hier à des
démissions parce que finalement on
arrive aussi à un moment donné
pour la raison personnelle pour des
raisons d'usure à ne plus supporter à se
dire que pour les années qu'on a encore
devant soi on a envie de faire d'autres
choses et que donc des tensions qui
pouvaient exister précédemment elles
sont moins acceptables passées passées
un certain âge et peut-être une question
pour pour vous monsieur présent ici vous
l'avez dit sur les tensions
démocratiques où vous avez vous avez
anticipé sur les violences mais
finalement on a 520 000 élus locaux on
leur rapport avec la population on a des
l'image d'une société
je vais le dire comme ça
est-ce que quand on a une Assemblée
nationale qui ne sait pas discuter et
changer s'affronter avec parfois la
violence que peut être celle du débat
politique mais en tout cas qui qui
cherchent toujours à répondre à un
intérêt qui est celui des Françaises et
des Français tout ceci alors je ne sais
pas si c'est ça descendant ou si ça
remonte d'en bas mais à un moment donné
nous amène bien évidemment vous le
disiez à
sur la performance d'une réunion
publique quand on ne discute pas et
quand on s'affronte on a eu encore des
exemples récemment dans dans des débats
à l'initiative du grand débat public sur
les enjeux du nucléaire qui ont été
complètement
polarisés et qui n'ont pas donné lieu au
débat qui est un débat qui peut être
contradictoire qui peut être parfois
dans la confrontation mais qui en tout
cas permet de dégager du commun dans le
sens que les différentes parties
construisent ensemble
merci Cécile
Eric
alors pour revenir sur quelques sujets
en complément de ce qui a été dit par
Martial Foucault la première chose c'est
la question des la question des chiffres
qu'il faudrait qu'on puisse objectiver
ensemble la question du chiffre des
démissions et de pourquoi cette émission
ces chiffres existent ils sont remontés
par toutes les préfectures c'est
incompréhensible qu'on n'arrive jamais à
nous faire
une synthèse exhaustive de ce qui se
passe exactement et comment parce que ça
permettrait de rompre avec certaines
avec certaines représentations après
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire c'est
si duckermann effectivement
alors pas faire de l'auto promotion mais
je vais renvoyer aussi à ce que j'ai
écrit sur ces sur ces sujets
si on regarde et qu'on s'intéresse aux
Blues des mers mais je l'avais écrit
avant les élections
il faut passer à cette image que tout va
que tout va mal
en revanche
les mers estiment que la situation dans
laquelle ils sont placés ou ils se
placent mais la plupart du temps ils
sont placés deviennent de plus en plus
impossible c'est surtout ça qui pose
problème
il y a toujours un sens et il le disent
et c'est ce que disait martial faut que
tout à l'heure il y a toujours un sens à
s'investir localement il y a toujours un
sens à donner de soi à la collectivité
en revanche
la question c'est eu égard à la
reconnaissance que j'obtiens est-ce que
ce don de soi a toujours la même valeur
et ça devient difficile parce qu'il est
de plus en plus difficile et c'est le
deuxième aspect d'arbitrer avec j'allais
dire le reste de la vie et donc avec la
vie
être élu notamment dans les communes les
moins peuplées ces données du temps de
soi donner du temps de sa famille et ne
pas pouvoir faire autre chose et quand
on regarde l'ensemble des motifs qui
amènent à renoncer ou pas à une carrière
politique ça joue ça joue énormément
moindre connaissance des conditions
démocratiques un petit peu plus
difficiles et puis aussi une technicité
martiale en a parlé qui est qui est de
plus en plus qui est de plus en plus
forte et qui empêche de faire donc c'est
pas tant le fait que il y a pas d'élus
qui veulent continuer à faire mais ils
estiment que les conditions dans
lesquelles ils sont mises sont de plus
en plus difficiles et parfois au-delà
des efforts qu'ils peuvent
qu'ils sont susceptibles de réaliser à
titre individuel ce qui amène bien
entendu à une question qui est celle en
filigrane
c'est que pour que les communes
continuent il faut qu'il y a encore des
mers alors bien entendu
les maires qui se représentent pas et en
fait quand on arrive aux élections ils
ont tendance à plus à plus se
représenter qu'on ne le déclarait
initialement
pour autant cette question elle va se
poser parce que le temps demandé et
c'est le temps le temps de la commune le
temps de l'internalité le temps de
l'ensemble des le temps est-elle qu'il
ne permet plus de faire autre chose à
côté et se pose en siligrain en
filigrane une question essentielle sur
laquelle on va revenir régulièrement
c'est que c'est difficile de penser à
l'avenir de la commune sans penser au
statut de l'élu et singulièrement au
statut des mers
après Jean-François Rapin pour finir
et merci
alors
ça part d'une question en fait que
je souhaitais vous poser sur des
chiffres que nous n'avons pas bien sûr
vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a 910
élus si j'ai bien compris qu'il y a
démissionnaire deux ans depuis 2020
910 élus et la question que je me posais
dont on n'a pas la réponse et parmi ces
élus combien y a-t-il de maires parce
que c'est pas exactement la même chose
un élu qui démissionne quand il est
aussi municipal il peut y avoir des tas
de raisons diverses et variés en fait
surtout s'il y a pas de délégation et
quand c'est un maire qui démissionne
donc en fait cumuler les deux ça c'est
pas un chiffre significatif pour moi
enfin voilà donc je sais que
c'est 910 mères donc c'est 900 diverses
qui me paraît important du coup voilà et
donc la question bien sûr c'était la
structure des des villes dans lesquelles
ces mers étaient élus autrement dit bien
entendu on ne l'a pas ça j'ai aussi
compris et donc c'est un rapport
directement avec une des raisons
exogènes parce qu'il y a des raisons
exogènes me semble-t-il qui est
effectivement la complexité
dont on a parlé et la complexité du fait
qu'on se retrouve avec un poste qui
devient poste excessivement technique
alors que c'était pas un poste technique
initialement c'était un poste politique
au sens noble du terme qui était celui
de la gestion et de l'avenir d'une ville
aujourd'hui ils deviennent très très
technique et donc forcément il doit
atteindre beaucoup plus les maires de
petites communes on a quelques exemples
ici qui n'ont pas de DGS qui n'ont pas
de service derrière pour assurer tout et
qui doivent aujourd'hui se retourner
vers le préfet ou le sous-préfet avec je
partagerai cet avis là un couple qui est
pas forcément la panacée en tout cas
qu'il a pas été autant qu'on l'a dit
donc c'est vrai que ça me paraît
important le deuxième point que je
voulais relever c'est sur la violence
j'ai fait un petit sondage personnel en
allant visiter 80% des maires des
communes de mon département
90% des réponses il n'y a pas plus de
violence aujourd'hui qu'il n'y en avait
il y a 5 ans où il y a 10 ans 90% des
réponses des maires des communes des
bouches de des Bouches-du-Rhône donc
c'est quand même un élément important
alors il y a une violence supplémentaire
qu'on ressent qui n'est pas la même qui
est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une
violence qui est lié aussi bien entendu
je crois que quelqu'un parmi vous l'a
dit au fait que la société elle-même est
devenue beaucoup plus violente et que
donc la violence qu'on retrouve dans la
société qui est pas forcément une
violence physique on la retrouve
également effectivement on peut la
retrouver dans les communes mais dans
ces communes là dans j'ai parlé
directement avec les mères c'est pas un
sondage fait par téléphone ou autre je
remarque que c'est une vraie question
noire qui se pose là et sur lequel je
pense qu'il faut essayer d'avoir une
vision un peu plus froide et essayer de
la en tout cas de l'argumenter voilà
cette violence
on a parlé du rôle du préfet se
terminerai à peu près sur ça on a parlé
du rôle du préfet avec les maires
il faut pas nier aussi qu'il y a pas que
le préfet qui peut avoir un rôle de
relation entre le maire et l'État bien
sûr c'est le représentant de l'état des
concentré mais il m'arrive et comme
beaucoup d'entre vous sûrement aussi
d'avoir aussi des relations qui
permettent avec certaines mères qui
permettent aux mères aussi d'avoir un
support une ressource nécessaire sur un
certain nombre de sujets en tout cas il
faut rappel à nous et je crois que c'est
notre rôle mais on essaye de jouer tous
au mieux d'assurer aussi cette
représentation quelque part de l'État ou
de la norme au sein du maire même si
c'est pas initialement notre notre
métier mais on est quand même les lieux
des mers et donc c'est aussi important
et enfin dernière chose
bien entendu il y a aussi un élément
important qui est celui quand même de la
structure des populations de vie
aujourd'hui le type de population chaque
ville c'est vrai que à l'époque où les
villes étaient peuplées essentiellement
de gens qui travaillaient sur place et
en particulier d'agriculteurs par
exemple le sujet bien entendu on a perdu
des millions d'agriculteurs en France on
le sait de paysans bien entendu le sujet
était absolument pas le même
qu'aujourd'hui ou dans des villes comme
la mienne une grotte partie de la
population n'est qu'une population qui
transite en fait qui vient dormir dans
la ville et qui en fait conçoit le maire
comme prestataire de service
pratiquement vous voyez et donc les
rapports et les relations soient pas les
mêmes alors c'est une raison qui n'a
rien à voir ni avec les mères ni avec
forcément la citoyenneté mais c'est une
c'est une des vraies causes aussi me
semble-t-il de cette difficulté à se
situer pour les mers
pour finir monsieur râpin merci
je reprends les éléments de Monsieur
Foucault parce qu'on a évoqué la crise
d'évocation
et d'ailleurs de façon tempérée vous
avez dit que c'est pas forcément des
vocations et je suis vraiment d'accord
avec vous moi je pense que c'est plutôt
une crise des volonté et plus on avance
plus on ira vers une crise des volonté
parce que c'est la société qui veut ça
parce que c'est
lié aussi aux observateurs de la vie des
mers qui considère aujourd'hui que elle
est plus compliquée qu'avant et moi pour
avoir été maire assez longtemps aussi
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je considère
que ceux qui nous succèdent aujourd'hui
ont un job alors je dirais pas du boulot
ni métier on te job beaucoup plus
difficile que ce qu'on a pu comprendre
pour les mêmes missions pour les
missions moi je le vois avec la dame qui
m'a succédé à la mairie elle a
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de Contra qui
était que je n'en avais pourquoi c'est
simple parce que nous je pense qu'on
avait on est on est d'une génération de
d'élus ou de mère où on avait le temps
de progresser on commençait par
l'acquisition des connaissances
progressivement quand on arrive mère
même si on a été conseillé municipal
même si on a été adjoint et ben on n'a
pas toutes les connaissances donc on a
la qui des connaissances qui se fait
progressivement on a la qui des
expériences qui se fait parce que
l'expérience d'un maire n'est pas du
tout celle de l'expérience d'un
conseiller municipal ou d'un adjoint
ouvert et puis en finalité ou peut-être
en même temps on a la proprio de
l'environnement général et je pense que
tout ça il y a une vingtaine d'années on
le faisait de façon beaucoup plus
progressive et en tout cas on n'avait
pas cette pression qu'on les met
aujourd'hui avec notamment et on l'a dit
les réseaux sociaux le manque de
reconnaissance parfois et donc il faut
qu'ils aillent plus vite à la fois dans
la qui des connaissances dans l'acquis
des expériences et dans de
l'environnement général ce qui à mon
avis est réellement
usant
usant et j'ai changé avec Didier Marie
on avait la même idée c'était de se dire
aujourd'hui mais finalement est-ce que
la voix choisie je sais que ça peut
faire rugir est-ce que la voix choisir
c'est pas de dire voilà on serait dans
un encadrement temporaire du mandat de
maire en se disant voilà si on fait
trois deux trois deux trois mandats
et bien on sera plus usé que quand on en
faisait 6 ou 7 mais on sera dans une
vision beaucoup plus pragmatique de ce
qu'est la vie du maire aujourd'hui en
lui disant voilà de toute façon au bout
de au bout d'un certain nombre d'années
vous ne le ferez plus et là je pense que
on peut aussi
se redonner la capacité d'avoir des
volontés parce que se posera plus la
question de se dire je suis tout seul
personne veut prendre ma succession je
vais devoir repartir et je vais devoir
repartir et là quand on entendit
effectivement qui après 60% des mers qui
au moment de se représenter
disent qu'ils vont pas y aller il faut
qu'on se pose la question de la crise de
volonté
merci
messieurs est-ce que vous avez quelques
réflexions par rapport à ce qui a été
dit ou quelques réponses à apporter
particulières
il faut réactiver vos micros
monsieur Loré on vous entend pas
parfait
de Monsieur Foucault effectivement
autre chose il a été évoqué là tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
appelle
on n'a pas établi la relation avec les
administrés cette relation elle est
constante avec des administrés il y a du
coût et du contre vous savez bien le
maire est
en volcan avec de la population et
[Musique]
la notion de de
violence qui a été évoquée là tout à
l'heure il me semble que c'est moins de
la violence et de l'agressivité parce
que le maire il est reconnu le maire
il est attendu au niveau de la
population mais il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes y sont dans
l'immédiateté
il souhaite à partir du moment où il
vous pose une question que vous soyez en
mesure d'apporter tout de suite la
réponse ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
et on est confronté à une forme
d'accessibilité non pas de violence mais
d'agressivité qui est dû je pense à une
question d'éducation tout simplement des
personnes parce que
la notion de respect se dilue dans le
temps au fur et à mesure et je crois
c'est surtout cela qui est en cause
parce que
à partir du moment où on est confronté à
ce type de comportement je crois
effectivement il n'y a que l'expérience
qui peut nous aider dans ce domaine là
c'est à dire en prenant suffisamment de
recul par rapport à cette agressivité
qui est déployée de façon à pouvoir
apporter la réponse adéquate en temps
voulu mais pas forcément dans l'immédiat
merci beaucoup
notre oui rapidement parce qu'on a je
crois dépasser le temps qui nous est
imparti
non très rapidement je voudrais apporter
deux précisions sur ce que j'ai voté
tout à l'heure j'ai regardé et le
chiffre est très
évocateur de la transformation de la
sociologie des maires en 1977
40% des mers étaient agriculteurs
en 2020
10%. donc c'est aller beaucoup plus vite
que la chute de la démographie du nombre
d'agriculteurs exploitants en France
pourquoi je dis cela parce que je crois
que ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure il
est vrai dans ce rapport qui peut
paraître par moment compliqué avec les
administrés j'insiste sur un point la
relation est globalement positive c'est
à dire que les administrés sont très
satisfaits de l'action d'un conseil
municipal globalement et donc il y a des
formes il existe malgré tout des moments
d'insatisfaction et ces moments
produisent et je rejoins ce que vient de
dire Monsieur le Maire c'est alors
violence agressivité incivilités il
faudra vraiment être très très précis
sur sur le choix des mots et parce que
chaque mot renvoie à des situations très
très particulières et qui et qui ne
doivent pas minorer un phénomène je
termine par là
qui est aussi ça a été évoqué sur une
mobilité résidentielle je crois qu'on a
un petit peu exagéré sur l'exode
vers les campagnes après la période
covid quand on regarde les données de
recensement de l'Insee là il y a pas
plus tard qu'un mois bon on voit que le
solde est assez stable par rapport à
2020 en revanche il y a
à la fois des témoignages et dans dans
des villes qui ont connu des
déplacements de population
essentiellement pour des raisons et
foncières et immobilières de
l'apparition mais comme on l'avait vu
dans le reste de la société une société
marchande on voit une forme de
consumérisme municipal qui conduit les
citoyens effectivement à exiger
et qui produit une forme de hiatus entre
une exigence dont parfois les mères sont
en mesure de répondre mais pas toujours
avec des demandes de nouvelles
mais là où ça produit un désarroi total
des équipes municipales c'est lorsque
ces demandes ne se coupe pas avec un
engagement des nouveaux résidents dans
la vie de la commune quel que soit les
activités et ça ça produit une une forme
de découragement violente pour pour les
mères voilà je voulais juste apporter
ces précisions mais pardon je rejoins
Éric et rouge sur la demande
je me dis quand même on a un appareil
statistique qui est pas si mauvais que
ça il ne cesse de s'améliorer ne pas
connaître le nombre précis élan
j'ignorais que Françoise Gatel serait là
mais sur ces 910 mères
j'ai simplement réussi à avoir deux
informations par département 32 mères
démissionnaires pour le Finistère et
l'île et Vilaine donc ce qui veut dire
que ces deux départements
enregisent des démissions beaucoup plus
élevées que la moyenne nationale
donc avoir ces informations ça me paraît
cruciale
là il nous faut vraiment travailler et
avoir ces informations et j'oublie un
point je sais pas si vous pourrez aller
dans ce sens mais connaître également
parce qu'on parle des démissions de mer
il faut parler des démissions des
adjoints des conseillers municipaux et
aussi et aussi parce que l'enquête nous
nous le révèle c'est l'absentéisme lors
des conseils municipaux on a un chiffre
alors c'est déclaratifs il faut être
prudent mais c'est 15% des maires qui
nous indiquent 15% des mers qui nous
indiquent que un conseil municipal sur 5
se tient au complet 1 sur 5
voilà bah écoutez
il nous reste à vous remercier messieurs
les maires
chers à Martial Foucault pour l'ensemble
de ces éléments nous ne manquerons pas
de réinterroger à l'envie et
avec un système à la fois la DGCL et
s'il le faut nous avons la capacité à
mener nos propres enquêtes puisque
chacune ou chacun des sénateurs pourra
dénombrer recensés dans leur département
respectifs celles et ceux qui depuis
2020 ont été amenés à à démissionner en
tout cas merci pour tous ces éléments
que vous nous avez livré d'une part
parce que et c'est plutôt rassurant
j'allais dire il corrobor ou en tout cas
il
illustrent par l'exemple ce que nous
avons pu chacune et chacun observer ce
qui a prévalu dans la mise en place de
cette de cette mission d'information et
ce qui va nous permettre finalement
d'avancer en explorant bien sûr les
éléments que vous avez souhaité ce soir
nous livrer en essayant d'apporter tant
que faire ce peu des des réponses des
préconisations parce que c'est aussi le
sens et l'objectif de cette de cette
mission et puis comme cela a été rappelé
nous ne manquerons pas aussi d'aller à
la rencontre des territoires sur les
territoires pour rencontrer j'allais
dire le maximum d'élus et notamment pour
répondre à ce que disait Cécile quierman
ceux des élus qui sont toujours en
fonction et qui auront nous n'en doutons
pas des éléments positifs aussi à nous
faire remonter parce qu'il y en a et
c'est surtout ce qui prévaut aujourd'hui
pour nous à les accompagner à leur
apporter ces éléments qu'ils appellent
de leurs vœux pour permettre de
faciliter l'exercice des mandats et de
leur mandats merci et puis on se donne
et puis on aura cela a été rappelé pour
répondre à ce que nous demandait la
dernière fois Eric qui rouche un sondage
que nous ne manquerons pas de regarder
de près pour voir les questions qui
seront posées à destination de la
population
pour voir ce que chacune et chacun des
Françaises et des Français attendent de
leur mère de leurs aides et de la façon
dont nous pouvons aussi répondre
utilement à leurs aspirations et à ce
besoin de proximité qu'il ne cesse
d'exprimer que vous avez rappelé dans
votre propos cher Marcel Foucault merci
à toutes et à tous et puis